keep your distance and wear a mask
it's the advice that's been given to
millions of people around the world and
following that recommendation has become
for many the norm but others refuse to
comply when you wear a mask what you can
certainly do you work six months into
the pandemic the use of face masks is
still up for debate
so is the recommended approach still the
way to go
[Music]
welcome to your Ovid nineteen special
here on DW I'm Cris cover and Berlin
these I'm tired of breathing through
them you might be as well but experts
say not wearing face masks during the
pandemic isn't an option and then
there's the u.s. no where is the
discussion around wearing face masks
probably as polarizing as in the United
States far from being merely tired of
them many people simply have never
wanted to wear them government to tell
you you have to wear a mask the time is
now it's time for action thank you guys
very much
anti maskers people who against the wide
consensus of public health experts
either one to limit masks wearing or are
against them completely any of them use
similar reasoning at the end I don't
wear a mask for the same reason I don't
under where things gotta breathe
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and on the other side critics have been
taking the country's most prominent anti
massacres so far the task in
increasingly creative ways
[Music]
hey just cover your freaking face like a
face mask I don't see it for myself I'm
choosing not to do it he might have even
gotten the message he started to change
his tune as of late I mean I'd have no
problem actually I had a mask on I said
I liked the way I looked okay I thought
it was okay it was a dark black mask and
I thought it looked okay he looked like
The Lone Ranger but no I have no problem
with it I think and if people feel good
about it they should do however the
president's decreasing a version two
masks influences attitudes
it will probably be mandatory mask
wearing policies that will make the
difference the number of states
requiring nose and mouth coverings like
New York and California are increasing
but calls are getting louder for a
nationwide masking policy proponents say
national measures would decrease
infection rates and save the country
from another round of shutdowns
and an estimated trillion dollar hit to
its economy something most people would
welcome maybe even anti maskers let's
talk more about this with Siddhartha
Varma he is an assistant professor for
ocean and mechanical engineering at
Florida Atlantic University welcome to
DW siddharta you examined the
effectiveness of various types of masks
and found significant differences which
was the most striking result of you very
thin single layer fabric as no doubt it
is better than nothing so any sort of
face covering is better than no covering
at all but the effectiveness can depend
a lot on the type of fabric that we use
if we are using cloth based in masks and
as well as on the fit on our faces so
with most masks we notice there was a
lot of leakage from the top where the
mask basically there is a gap between
our nose and the mask so it's important
to have both good fit that's comfortable
let's use good tightly woven fabrics so
what would be the best fabric in order
for the mask to work properly the best
fabric that we tested was actually two
layers of quilting cotton they were just
stitched together and we fitted snugly
on the face and you could see that the
forward motion of the jet was restricted
to barely 2 or 3 inches and that turned
out to be the best yeah so if I have a
mask like that or any other type how can
I test if it is holding back aerosols in
a proper fashion so some people have
suggested a very simple test would be
hold it up hold your mask up to a light
and if you do see that the mask blocks
the light well it's likely to be more
effective
okay what about wearing your mask with
your nose out does that make any sense
at all if you go out on the street you
see people doing that well some people
do that and no you should keep your nose
covered by the mask for two reasons
first you know when we exhale if we are
infected we might be we will definitely
exhale the virus little droplets out and
another risk is must-do prevent the
wearer to some extent so we are we would
be protecting ourselves by covering our
noses so we minimize the amount of
droplets that we breathe in as well and
as these masks come in many styles and
fashions
Siddartha what is your mask of your
choice I actually wear a surgical type
mask and it's because they are easily
available but I have a few homemade
masks as well so I switch out between
these types
alright siddharta Verma of the Florida
Atlantic University thank you for
talking to
GW sure thank you for having now wearing
your mask is particularly important when
you cannot keep your distance because
sometimes we have to visit these crowded
places like a train station for example
now I start up in Munich is focusing on
a new pedestrian control system to
ensure that people will not have to pass
each other in close proximity and still
get to where they want to go on time
preventing potentially dangerous crowds
that's what this team of computer
scientists and simulation experts is
working on and accurate a startup based
in Munich the corona pandemic is also
demanding that they take a few steps
into the unknown the team usually
calculates evacuation plans and security
measures for major events or passenger
flows what's new is that they now want
to protect passengers employees and
visitors from koban 19 as much as
possible the corona crisis in particular
has shown us that simulations now not
only help with crowds of people but they
can also help us to see how many people
we can fit in a room while observing
social distancing rules so it concerns
office buildings but also train stations
so that passengers can travel safely the
simulations are based on projections
human avatars so-called agents follow
lifelike movement patterns here we
already have built-in social distancing
that means we have a green circle around
a person with the diameter of 3 meters
or a radius of 1 meter 50 how are they
all supposed to get out now and here I
can already see that maybe these people
are going to come out too but they'll
have to wait a bit who will actually go
through a 1 meter wide door first if I
have to keep a 1.5 meter distance and
you can see that the agents turn red
from time to time that means they've
been under the minimum distance for a
while the test avatars are still moving
about without fear of infection
researchers are focusing on a new
pedestrian control system to ensure that
in the future people will not have to
pass each other in close
proximity to reach their destinations on
time we are already seeing queuing
systems everywhere in our daily lives
whether it's the entrance to the
supermarket and so on and so forth I
think their research work we're talking
about has something to do with the
queuing system and actually tries to
capture and describe what's happening
there and the findings can of course
help us to plan queues with a different
set of objectives the minimum distance
can even shorten travel routes and
waiting times and train stations or
mezzanines the one-way street regulation
can stop people getting in each other's
way when getting off for changing trains
the accurate team combines user
information and architectural data which
it hopes will help facilitate a return
to normal and that means pedestrian
traffic and what that public life could
flow a little more smoothly again it's
time now to answer your questions about
Kovach 19 he is our science science
correspondent Derek Williams what are
the risks of sharing bathrooms with non
family members like at the office this
question has been coming up a lot ever
since the publication of a new study on
the physics of how aerosols are
generated when you flush the toilet
Chinese researchers who modeled it
discovered that every time you flush
without closing the seat cover it sends
a plume of aerosols up into the air
which will will hover for minutes and
and then eventually settle on surfaces
with other studies indicating that the
virus might at least sometimes survive
passage through the digestive tract
suddenly those public facilities we all
need to visit once in a while look like
a potentially dangerous environment
especially because many public or shared
toilets are also enclosed windowless
spaces that said the experts that I've
read on this mostly don't expect them to
become
beds of infection probably because
everyone's grown so leery of using
public facilities if you have to though
um you should of course take the
standard precautions particularly when
it comes to to washing your hands
afterwards but but hopefully you were
doing that anyway are there any
indications that covered 19 causes brain
damage what does it only affect the
peripheral nervous system it can affect
both our views on what this virus does
to the body continue to evolve but we
but we now know that it's far more than
just a pumped up version of a cold virus
that only affects the respiratory system
it can affect many different organs
including the brain current estimates
say that around around half of all kovat
19 patients with with severe cases will
display neurological symptoms at some
point either due to too low oxygen
levels in the blood or the body's own
inflammatory response and and that they
could also sustain neurological damage
often often from strokes but also
possibly directly from the virus itself
it now appears that at least in some
cases SARS Cove 2 crosses what's known
as the blood-brain barrier which which
usually protects the brain from invasion
by pathogens the problem is is that
neurological symptoms and their causes
are notoriously difficult for doctors to
track back and to quantify which is why
we haven't heard that much about them so
far during this pandemic but because
neurological or nerve damage can cause
lifelong problems many experts believe
that kovat 19 will leave behind a
devastating legacy that will we'll only
discover in the years to come
you